let's bring in dana perino now co-anchor
of america's newsroom and co-host of the
five and she is on set on the phone that
was so confusing
it is confusing we're watching this
motorcade pull out there and at the end
when the fro
you saw the frustration from the
reporters in the room saying wait a
second only six or seven uh reporters
got questions and 21 are in the room and
not only that he said he was late and
had to leave but they just pushed up the
news conference 90 minutes from the 3
o'clock eastern time plan news
conference i don't know if you make
anything of that well i think moving it
up you'd have to it's curious right so
is it because the president wanted to be
done with his day early look i used to
work for a president who liked to get
things done early and you if you were
not early you were late so i get that
but that's not typical with this
president um it could be that they had
enough agreement um and that everything
that they needed to do in the meeting
was done early okay fine
he didn't take enough questions you have
to
understand that these reporters they've
gone all the way over there they're
sitting there waiting they have so much
so many questions
and even though the answers might have
been
less than what zolensky was wanting or
that we were wanting he was actually
having a pretty good press conference so
to me like why not just keep going
because there was enough hunger in the
room
that he could have continued to answer
he was pretty sharp i have to tell you i
wouldn't have answered the question on
the 2024 election the way he did i would
not have done that on foreign soil i
would have said i'm honored to be the
president of the united states 2024 is a
long way away we'll talk about it then
do you have a question about today's
subject i would never have done that on
foreign soil you know don't don't forget
dana that the longer he takes questions
the more the chances that one of them
doesn't come out of it the one answer
doesn't come out of his mouth as it
should it was that famous uh press
conference not too long ago where he
started taking question after question
after question and finally said well if
it's a small incursion that's one thing
and then boom you know the cat was out
of the bag there and i think the private
conversation suddenly became very public
but in terms of this this
argument that has been made by the
president's critics that he doesn't seem
to be playing to win here with ukraine
what signal do you think he sent to
vladimir putin and to ukraine on that
front
i
can i say that i don't think it was very
different than what vladimir putin would
have thought this morning
i mean did vladimir putin need to hear
from the president 20 times that nato is
has never been as united i think we all
see that
that's a good thing we are happy about
that but that's that's not new
um i have to imagine that there has to
be some sort of back channel
communication to zielinski so that he
gets a little bit more i there were a
couple of things he said that i think
were worth it one
and putin would take notice of this
maybe he wouldn't be surprised but the
president was definitive that putin and
russia should not be in the g20
yeah and you know putin had built the
economy to the point where he could be a
part of the g20 and no more and that
or at least if the other countries don't
agree to it uh the president said well
then ukraine should join as well which
basically effectively makes the g20
pointless so i i did think there was a
little bit of news there and he was
quite definitive on that point yeah he
said he um he was uh asked uh whether or
not uh russia needs to be removed from
the g20 he said definitively yes
personally he believes that depends on
the g20
dana on food shortages another
interesting moment uh it's going to be
real said president biden and
that's pretty much fact right now
there's going to be a major squeeze on a
lot of global commodities we talk about
energy all the time but when it comes to
those grains that feed the world it is
going to be a real struggle and so when
i was on the phone with you and that was
this change i mentioned that this is one
of the issues i'm sure that they're
going to talk about because there are
real national security implications to
hunger around the world if you remember
the arab
arab spring a lot of people might
remember that and say oh that was about
twitter right no
the wheat prices had gone up so much
and there was so much frustration when
you have problems like food costs going
up this much you will have uprisings
uprisings lead to what emigration and
also famine and starvation so it's not
only the grain that's a huge problem but
also many farmers all around the world
get their fertilizer from russia
so our farmers are about to do their
plantings in the next four weeks if they
don't get enough fertilizer we're not
going to have enough food here either
this is a very real problem apparently
nato has talked about it and it is
something that everyone has to think
about not just because there's a moral
obligation to make sure people have
enough food but there's a national
security implication as well so what
about this non-red line red line that
the president drew when it comes to
chemical weapons so the president said
that it would trigger a response the
type of response would be
uh what
measured by whatever the attack was and
then he said after that that there would
be a response in kind
i'm not sure that in kind were the words
that he was actually looking for because
the chemical response in kind would be a
chemical response and we're not about to
do that so what did you make of what he
said there well i know i understand that
that the white house has taken on board
the criticism that the president has
ruled out too many things that he will
not do okay and people are saying why
you why not leave a little bit more
mystery but then it just seemed like as
you just described the answer it does
seem a little bit more muddled well if
it's this then it's that but it could be
and we'll have to take into
consideration instead of just saying
we'll let you know but we're on to you
right you don't have to describe exactly
what you're going to do and you
certainly shouldn't draw a red line if
you're not going to adhere to it as we
saw in syria back in 2012 2014 excuse me
so there was a lot of talk about what
the president could do to change the
current perception of the current
sitting u.s president on the world stage
i believe the wall street journal wrote
about this as we were working our way
into the week anticipating the
president's arrival and visit there do
you believe the president said or did
anything on the global stage just now to
change the way
the world sees this president
you know i don't know i think that i
think it's very good that he went i
think it's good that they had a
face-to-face meeting and a lot of the
most important things in any meeting
happen behind closed doors so maybe
we'll hear a little bit more about that
and that was the first time he had a
chance to meet the new prime minister of
japan for example that's a very
important alliance so now in the sort of
post kovitish world the fact that he's
there the fact that he made these
statements i thought many of the answers
were pretty sharp
and he seemed like he had energy and so
i would say
net plus so far
interesting dana preno's analysis thank
you very much for joining us on set dana
thanks for having me okay john thanks
dana we'll see you again soon okay hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else